uh let's take a look Chase would you
rather smash the hottest trans woman in
the world or the oldest woman in the
world honestly bro the oldest woman in
the world because then I wouldn't be gay
you really just want me to just uh
I swear are you like Chase how dare you
be transphobic Yes actually do you mean
yes because if I had sex with a trans
woman I'd be having sex with a
biological man and I don't want to do
that that's not good I don't care if
you're doing this for like whatever but
like that's too far she says not wanting
to have sexual relations with a man is
is too far his Center his
heterosexuality is simply a bridge too
far for this young lady who along with
her friend has no choice but to flee the
room and discuss we must admit though
that she made a compelling argument to
quote her she says I don't even care if
you're doing this for like whatever but
like shut the f up actually that's the
kind of quote that would make Mark Twain
proud